やあみんな、はじめしゃちょーだよ
僕は前回、ちょっと前にですね、あの…
巨大風船をこうポンプで膨らませて爆発させる動画を撮ったんですけど、
見事失敗したんで、
今回はそのリベンジってわけでね、
今こちらに…やば。
巨大風船の水風船バージョンを準備しました。
なんか…なんか、エロいね
無理だホース入んねえな、ホース取れたりしないのか
あ、取れるじゃん! もう…入れて、入れろと言わんばかりのこの感じ
おお!
やばい、やばいぞ、ちょっと怖くなってきた
いややばい…これはやばい
結構やばいんですけど、
今日はね、まあ前回ブレイブバーストできなかったわけなんで、
もう僕は正直かなり悔しいんですよ今。
もう風船見たらもう、すぐぶち割りたくなるぐらいちょっと今…
アレなんで、今日はこのね、巨大風船に、自らこう…ジャンピング乗りして、
えっ?
大丈夫だよね
ジャンプ乗りして、完璧にブレイブバーストをね。
今日は、きれいにキメようと思います
じゃあもう、ちょっと爆発寸前で怖いんでぱぱっとやっちゃいましょう。
ええ、うそぉ!
自分で言っといて嫌になってきたな、、
よし、じゃあ行きます。行きますよ?
行きますよ!? 俺本当に知らねぇぞ、これ。
やべえぞ、これ…いや大丈夫。これはもう大丈夫。俺は…レジェンドになる。じゃ行きます。
スリー、ツー、ワン!
え、ちょっとまてスリーツーワンじゃねえや、ちょっと待って待って待って、、
え、えー!! いややばちょっと待った、マジか! 嫌になってきた!
嫌ではないけど…ちょっと失うものがでかい気がする
行くぞ…スリー、ツー、ワン。
やばい!!
やばい!
ちょ、大洪水大洪水。
ちょっと待った待った待った待った。やばいやばいやばい。部屋的なやばい。
部屋的なやばい、これは。 これ部屋的な、部屋的なやばいだ。
これやばい、部屋的なやばいやつだ…。